okay so on Monday we talked about how
cell division is regulated at this
single cell level on Wednesday we talked
about how regeneration is mediated at
the level of an entire tissue and today
we're going to talk about how all of
that can go wrong okay and when all of
this goes wrong it results in a disease
that's actually many different diseases
but are commonly known as cancer okay
and as illustrated in this cartoon what
you see is that cancer can often be
defined as having distinct steps and
it's a progressive essentially
deregulation of normal cell and tissue
behavior okay so when we're thinking
about cancer we're thinking about a
stepwise degeneration and cancer is a
disease that affects an individual's own
cells but those cells get progressively
and progressively dysregulated in their
behavior and their court the
coordination of their behavior with the
rest of the tissue so it's a stepwise
degeneration of normal cell behavior and
it results from mutations that are
occurring in the cell and we'll talk
about what types of mutations right now
and then we'll I'll take you through
some examples of different signaling
pathways and we'll try to classify what
different types of genes should be
labeled as okay so first I want to talk
about classes of genes and their
involvement in cancer
and the first example that I'll take you
through is known as an oncogene and it's
referred to as an oncogene after the
mutation has already happened and so an
oncogene oncogenic mutation is a
mutation that's going to promote growth
and survival of an of a cell so this
promotes growth before the gene is
mutated it's referred to as a
proto-oncogene so before mutated the
gene is labeled a proto-oncogene and the
normal function of these proto-oncogenes
is also to promote growth and survival
but they do so in a regulated manner so
gene becomes an oncogene when there's a
mutation that causes it to be
unregulated by the environment of the
cell or even the surroundings of the
cell and so you can think of this as a
constitutive activation often oncogenes
are constitutively active forms of
normal genes okay and one way to think
about this is you have a gene whose
normal function is to promote growth and
it's kind of stuck in the state of the
gene that always promotes growth which
is not normally how it works normally
there are signals that tell us cell to
grow and those signals come and go and
that's how the body regulates when cells
divide but you can have a situation
where it's essentially the equivalent of
what you might consider a stuck
accelerator if you're thinking about an
automobile so if you have this stuck
accelerator
and you can only speed up and you can't
slow down this is analogous to an
oncogenic mutation now a different class
of gene that's actually the kind of the
opposite of an ink Anka gene is called a
tumor suppressor and tumor suppressors
are genes whose normal function is to
inhibit growth or even promote death
okay so tumor suppressors inhibit growth
or promote death right you can see how
these two different things would have
the same effect and that it's not
allowing one cell to become a lot of
cells because the tumor suppressor will
either prevent it from dividing or will
cause the cells to die okay
and so the cancer phenotype is
associated with
a loss of function of the tumor
suppressor okay so these result from
loss of function mutations in the tumor
suppressors right so if you remove the
thing that's inhibiting growth then that
allows the cells to divide in a more
unregulated way okay and so sticking
with the analogy of an automobile you
could think of a tumor suppressor music
mutation as a cell having defective
breaks okay so we can think of this as
defective breaks
okay so it's the loss of function of
these that lead to cancer now I want to
tell you about one last class of genes
that are implicated in cancer and these
are what in the diagram up there are
referred to as caretaker genes and what
that refers to is the fact that these
genes are involved in maintaining the
genomic integrity of a cell okay and
they can do that by mediating DNA repair
when it needs to happens so these are
involved in in the repair of DNA or
actually I know it all say we'll say
genome it's involved in genome repair
but not only repair but also genome
stability right so making sure that
chromosomes are equally segregated to
daughter cells so that you don't end up
with cells with extra chromosomes or
lacking entire chromosomes which is
known as being an employed so genome
repair and also integrity okay
and again it's because these promote
genome integrity it's a loss of the
function of these genes that is what
promotes cancer okay so a loss of
function mutations and caretaker genes
are what can drive a cancer phenotype
and that's because if you lose a
caretaker gene that's involved in DNA
repair actually one of one example of a
caretaker gene is the brca1 gene which
is involved in breast cancer and so if
you lack this brca1 gene it makes it so
that the cells are not as good at
repairing their da
and then the cell can accumulate
additional mutations and the cell might
get an oncogenic mutation or it might
lose tumor suppressors and that's what
drives the cancer phenotype okay now I
just want to point out something that
just happened this week which is that
one of our very own colleagues here at
MIT and gelik aiment on whose lab has
done a lot of research that has provided
fundamental insights into how a lack of
genome integrity influences both normal
and cancer cells she just won what's
known as the breakthrough prize and so
this is a prize that was initiated by a
Chan Zuckerberg initiative so it's out
of Silicon Valley and the point of the
prize is to basically celebrate science
like we would like movies at the Oscars
and so this is Angelica here receiving
this breakthrough award and this just
happened this past weekend and this is
for her fundamental work on how
aneuploidy influences the biology not
only of normal cells but also cancer
cells okay because it plays an important
role in the biology of cancer all right
so now that we've defined some of these
key genes I want to talk about one
example of a pathway that influences
cell division and we'll go through all
the genes in this pathway and decide
whether or not they should be considered
oncogenes tumor suppressors or
caretakers and the pathway we're going
to look at involves the g1 to ask
transition
and you'll recall that this g12 s
transition in the cell cycle is referred
to as start and is the point in which an
individual cell commits to going through
the entire cell cycle okay so this g1 s
transition or start what kicks off the
whole process is the expression of a
cyclin and that is specifically the g1
cyclin
this g1 cyclin
many different things and we've talked
about a lot of them first of all there
are growth signals these are secreted
proteins that allow cells to communicate
with each other and many growth signals
promote growth and cell division by up
regulating this g1 cyclin
regulating the gene expression of this
particular cyclin gene okay we also
talked about wint and wint is another
type of signaling system and one of its
target is target's is also the g1 cyclin
so both of these signals promote growth
there are also other types of signals
like cytokines which also promote g1
cyclin
control point for the cell to decide
whether or not to enter into the cell
cycle I'll point out that there are also
other types of signals that inhibit
growth and I'll call those growth
inhibitors and so these growth
inhibitors inhibit g1 cyclic spreche in'
so if you have a cell in your body and
it's trying to decide whether or not to
divide its it's basically reading out
like how many growth positive signals at
seeing versus growth negative signals
and it's able to integrate that
information based on how much g1 cyclin
that determines whether or not it goes
into the cell cycle okay
so g1 cyclin d1 cyclin functions with
cyclin-dependent kinase so this depends
on cyclin dependent kinase this
eventually leads to the expression of
the g1 to s cyclin and it's the g1 to s
cyclin which is responsible for
activating the transition from g1 to s
which is known as start in yeast in the
restriction point in mammalian cells
okay but it all starts really with this
g1 cyclin
so i want to talk about this step in the
cell cycle and I'll show you the
nitty-gritty of the mechanisms that are
involved and we'll talk about what types
of genes all of these genes are and it's
going to involve a very important gene
that's gonna that I'm going to tell you
a lot more about in just a few minutes
alright so the critical determinant of
start is this g1 s cyclin so I'm drawing
a piece of DNA here here's the g1 s
cyclin gene so this is DNA just drew a
piece of DNA part of the genome this is
the g1 s cyclin gene okay and this gene
is activated its transcription is
activated by a transcription factor
known as e to F ok so we'll keep track
of what these are e to F is a
transcription factor
okay so e to F is a transcription factor
that will activate the expression of
this G 1s cyclin but in early g1 there's
a protein that binds to e to F and this
protein is called RB I'll tell you what
RB stands for in just a minute but what
RB does is it binds to e to F and it
inhibits its transcriptional activity
okay
so an early g1 e to F is inhibited and
the expression of this G 1s cyclin is
off okay so this is off or repressed
okay okay so before the cell passes
start this expression is off okay so
this is early g1 before start now what
happens is this state is changed by the
g1 cyclin d1 adequate levels of g1
cyclin dependent kinase B as cyclones
always their functions are always
mediated through cyclin dependent kinase
so the Cyclones are never as far as I
know functioning on there by themselves
they're always functioning through this
site one of the cyclin dependent kinase
is okay so g1 cyclin-cdk phosphorylates
RB and so you then get an RB that has a
bunch of phosphates attached to it
and this inhibits our bees function such
that it can't bind to e to F so when
cyclic g1 cyclin-cdk phosphorylates our
bee that causes our bee to go away from
the promoter of the g1 s cyclin and now
you have this transcription factor e to
F free to transcribe the g1 s cyclin
gene okay so this now gets turned on and
it's this activation of g1 s gene
expression which is the signal to
undergo you get g1 s cyclin CDK because
you express this gene and that activates
the transition into S phase okay alright
now take a look at sort of everything I
just drew on the board who can tell me
where the tumor suppressors are in this
pathway miles
[Music]
Arby is a tumor-suppressor that's
exactly right let me get some colored
chalk here
alright I'm gonna circle tumor
suppressors in pink there are any other
tumor suppressors so RB is a tumor
suppressor yeah Amanda did you have one
Amanda Georgia Georgia sorry the growth
inhibitors are also tumor suppressors
exactly
okay how about uncle genes or what would
be considered a proto-oncogene in the
system jeremy cdk would be one yep so
uncle genes cdk could be considered in a
proto-oncogene anything else
well what defines an oncogene or a
proto-oncogene what's its normal
function in the cell carbon yes mm-hmm
so it promotes growth and moving a cell
along the cell cycle will promote growth
so yes exactly so anything here
promoting growth
besides CDK e to F would be a
proto-oncogene sure Jeremy did you have
an idea g1 cyclin
everything else here would be considered
a proto-oncogene right Winstar proto
oncogenes they're promoting growth by
promoting the expression of g1 cyclin
B's growth signaling the the growth
signaling pathway all of those genes
would be considered proto oncogenes and
so anything that is promoting growth
will be a proto-oncogene here great all
right so now we're gonna move on and
talk about this RB gene which I just
showed you mechanistically what it does
but what RB stands for is retinoblastoma
so our B stands for retinoblastoma and
this RB gene as you suggested is a tumor
suppressor it was actually the first
tumor suppressor that was cloned and so
retinoblastoma as the name implies is
involved in a human disease and it's
involved in a rare childhood
I tumor so I'm gonna show you one last
weird I picture if you don't want to
look look down or look the other way I'm
gonna show you a child that has
retinoblastoma and what it looks like so
it's gonna appear right now so this is
an individual with retinal blastoma you
can see that there's something inside
the eye growing in the back of it and to
give you a better picture of what is
happening this is now a cross-section
through a normal eye this is a cartoon
of the normal eye and individuals with
retinal blastoma have a growth in the
back of the eye which is the rep from
the retinal tissue you can see this huge
tumor that's present in the back of this
eye okay so this disease involves the
formation of these tumors in the eye
that originated from the retinal tissue
alright so so this this disease results
it is this is a tumor suppressor it's a
loss of function in the retinoblastoma
so there's a defect in the
retinoblastoma gene but this disease of
retinal blastoma
manifests itself in different ways okay
so there are different forms of the
disease and I'll tell you how they're
different right now so there are two
forms of the disease the first is called
it's called sporadic sporadic
and it's called sporadic because this is
a form of the disease that arises in
families that have no history of the
disease so the sporadic form the family
has no history of the disease and this
disease presents in a certain way the
first is is what is known as unilateral
meaning it usually only one eye is
affected so it usually involves only one
eye and this this disease can be treated
in children and if it's this particular
the sporadic form of the disease is
treated in the child then later on in
life that individual does not have an
increased risk of getting further tumors
okay so there's no increased risk of
cancer later in life for example in a
different organ okay
so this is one form of the disease the
other form of the disease is called
familial and as the name implies
familial means that the disease runs in
the family okay so both familial means
is there's there's some inheritance
there's an inherited form of the disease
okay and the familial form of the
disease can be distinguished from the
sporadic form because it presents
differently the way the familial form
presents is it's often bilateral meaning
that both eyes become affected so it
affects both eyes
and also in individuals with the
familial form even when they're cured
from the eye tumors they have a higher
risk of getting other tumors and other
organs of their body later on in life
okay so there's in this case there is
later an increased risk of cancer in
other organs so this is an example of a
familial form of retinoblastoma where
affected individuals here are colored in
green so what would you say the
inheritance pattern is for this
particular phenotype
Carmen why do you say autosomal
recessive can you explain your logic so
Carmen is exactly right and she's saying
that both males and females are getting
it so it looks like that would argue
that it's not sex linked but autosomal
so it looks autosomal and why do you say
recessive can you explain your logic
there yep yeah so Carmen is exactly
right if you have she's looking at this
individual here and in this case this
individual was not affected with the
disease but passed on the disease to
their daughters okay now I think one one
thing this is an exception to the rule
what you see in pretty much all the
other cases is that individuals in this
generation in the middle here do have
the disease and they pass on the disease
to the next generation so because I'm
seeing the disease in all generations
all I would say that this is more likely
to be autosomal dominant and Carmen
Carmen picked up on something that I
want to come to it so happens that this
individual was not affected by the
disease and but still clearly carried a
disease allele and I'm going to talk
about why
this is an exception and why this is
still an autosomal dominant inheritance
pattern okay but this if we take for if
we take it that this is an autosomal
dominant disease this kind of brings up
this kind of counterintuitive at least
to me and maybe to you because I just
told you that tumor suppressors result
from a loss of function of the gene okay
and we're used to seeing loss of
function mutations being recessive okay
and actually at the cellular level it's
true this is the cancer is recessive
okay but in this case what you see is
that at the organismal level that the
inheritance pattern actually acts as a
dominant phenotype okay so there's kind
of a difference between the inheritance
pattern at the cell level and at the
organismal level okay and I want to tell
you why that is because I think it's
important for understanding you know the
risk to cancer and so what's being
inherited here is not what's inherited
is not the full-blown disease okay
what's inherited in the case of
retinoblastoma and many other cancers is
a predisposition to the disease okay so
what is inherited is the predisposition
to the disease okay and that's because
if we look at let's consider the top
male up here right if that mal is
heterozygous for the RB gene then it can
then he can have a gamete which is RB -
okay so lacking a functional copy of the
RB gene and he married an individual
without a disease allele so there's
gonna gonna just make RB plus gametes
okay and if you if they have children
and the children of the children gets a
gamete that is derived from the RB minus
allele then you get an individual and
the zygote here which has one functional
copy of the RB gene and one mutant copy
of the RB gene okay so that's the egg
and then that egg is going to develop
and give rise to all of the cells of the
body and so in this case all of the
somatic cells from this individual are
going to be heterozygous for the RB gene
so all somatic cells are heterozygous
for RB so there are RV + / RB - and the
effect of that is is it means that each
of the cells and this individual are
only one step away or one mutation away
from lacking both copies of our B okay
so by being heterozygous it means that
all cells and the individual are just
one mutation
or step from losing our be okay and so
the inheritance pattern what you're
looking at is the predisposition to the
disease and the predisposition doesn't
mean that a person is guaranteed to get
the disease and that's illustrated in
this family tree right there was an
individual here this male here with the
arrow who clearly was a carrier for the
disease because he passed on the disease
to his children but who himself never
actually was affected by the disease
okay so because it's a predisposition it
doesn't mean there's a guarantee that if
you if you are heterozygous for RB
there's not a guarantee that you're
going to have the disease but you are
going to be predisposed to it and in the
case of RB more often than not if you
lack one functional copy of RB and are
heterozygous for all your cells then
you're going to be affected by the
disease does that make sense Carmen okay
so it's basically because the yeah
Jeremy well actually if you are
homozygous from RB the individual would
probably not be born yeah so it would be
almost I think would be impossible to be
heterozygous for RB yeah so really what
you're inheriting here is the
predisposition and because the
predisposition just requires
heterozygosity
it manifests itself like a dominant
phenotype right because you only need to
inherit one allele that's mutant in
order to be predisposed to get the
disease okay so that that's why it
appears that the organismal level to be
a dominantly inherited phenotype okay
but then to get the disease
you need to lose a second copy of the
gene and so for the sporadic form of the
disease so we just talked about
hereditary or familial retinoblastoma
all of the cells of the individual will
start out being heterozygous and then
some of them will lose what is known as
lose hetero zygosity and become
homozygous mutant in a particular tissue
okay and that would be the tumor tissue
so what are some ways that there could
be this loss of heterozygosity can you
guys come up with some possible ways to
do that hetero zygosity how might a cell
lose that second copy of RB what are
some potential mechanisms that you could
lose it Rachel it could be a point
mutation exactly right so one way would
be point mutation in RB other ideas
yeah Patricia
yeah
so if you like lose a chromosome right
so if you guys remember back remember
way back when we are all young men and
women in early October we did the whole
demonstration with mitosis and we had a
case where you we had two good friends
across the metaphase plate and that
brought both pairs that all both sister
chromatids off to one side right that
would result in loss of a chromosome and
in this case if you have a division and
you lose the wild type copy of RB if you
lose that entire chromosome then you're
going to be left with only the mutant
copy of the RB okay so another mechanism
would be chromosome loss with a
chromosome that's lost as the chromosome
with the wild-type rb+ allele okay and
the other ideas as to how you might lose
the the second functional copy of RB
yeah miles yeah you could have DNA
damage you have like a deletion that
deletes the entire region of the
chromosome that contains our B there
could be even like chromosomal
abnormalities like translocations that
somehow delete RB so I'll just say
deletion for now any others can anyone
think of something that wouldn't be
necessarily a genetic change but more
than epigenetic change so to speak
yeah Natalie with without being what are
you being mutagenize but then that would
cause a mutation which would might fall
into one of these three classes here
what about without being mutagen eyes
non mutagenic non mutagen non mutagenic
yeah
Maxwell they're environmental factors
that control expression yeah so Maxwell
is saying what else would control the
expression of the RB gene right what if
you had an effect that would basically
cause that functional copy of RB to be
not expressed okay and so this is
another way that you can lose hetero
zygosity
as you have repression of transcription
and I'm not going to go through the
nitty-gritty of the details but one way
in which genes are regulated is by
modification of DNA by chemical
modifications like methylation and so
promoter methylation is a mechanism that
causes repression of gene expression and
in many cases in cancer the functional
copy of a tumor suppressor will
basically be lost by promoter
methylation so that you no longer
express that gene in that cancer cell
and therefore the the cancer cell has a
cancer phenotype okay any questions on
RB before I move on okay everyone
understands why retinal blastoma is
dominant at the organismal level yet
recessive at the cell level that's an
important point right because it's also
the the concept behind that is also the
same for brca1 and other tumor
suppressors like p53 and APC which
you'll see in just a minute okay
all right so now I want to move up kind
of from thinking about the mechanism of
cancer at the level of a cell and let's
think about it at the level of the
tissue and as an example I want to use
colon cancer and you'll recall from
Wednesday I talked about the intestine
as a system and the way it works is
pretty much the same for both the small
and the large intestine it just happens
in the large intestine or the colon you
don't have villi but you do still have
these crypts okay so that would be what
a colon would look like more or less or
at least one crypt of a colon and
remember there was this at the base of
the crypt there was a specialized
compartment which was the stem cell
niche and this is where renewal was
happening and renewal and cell division
down at the base of the crypt then
results in this conveyor belt like
movement up to the region of the tissue
near the lumen where cells are shed off
into the lumen okay so what might be one
step you can envision that a cancer or
one barrier to cancer that has to be
overcome in order for a tumor to form in
this organ
[Music]
yeah so miles is saying is that these
cells are going to move up and get shut
off and so if you have a mutation in
either an oncogenic mutations or loss of
tumor suppressors right if it goes up in
sheds and is removed from the organ it
doesn't matter that cell is not going to
be able to form a tumor so one thing
that has to happen for a cell to form a
tumor in this system is this treadmill
has to be blocked such that cells are no
longer exiting the organ so that you
have a cell actually stay in the organ
that would be able to accumulate
additional mutations and undergo
tumorigenesis okay and this is this is
what happens B as we know in colon
cancer one of the first steps in colon
cancer is dysregulation of the signaling
that really regulates this movement of
cells and the sort of homeostasis of the
tissue okay so step one here step one is
to dis regulate the main signaling
pathway that's involved in this which is
wind signaling and so another famous
tumor suppressor is called
the APC gene this is a tumor suppressor
bless you
and this APC gene is associated with
another familial form of cancer in this
case its familial adenomatous polyposis
and so this is a normal colon normally
your colon has a smooth surface
it's basically smooth here I mean there
are some folds but I'm not sure that
that's not an effect of having this
dissected out of the organism but within
individuals with familial adenomatous
polyposis what happens is that the colon
forms many of these polyps which are
benign sort of cancer out growths okay
but you see all these polyps here and
you see how very different the
morphology of the colon is from a normal
individual and an individual that has
familial adenomatous polyposis okay
so this is the formation of a polyp is
kind of equivalent to something like
this it's it's not invasive yet it's it
would be known as benign but you can see
that there's clearly a dysregulation and
how this tissue is behaving because you
get all of these polyps forming and it's
thought that frank carcinoma then
results from one of these polyps cells
in one of these polyps accumulating
additional mutations that then cause the
cancer to progress to a more malignant
stage okay so I told you that APC is the
tumor suppressor that is and in this
case it's frequently well it's in this
case this tumor suppressor is associated
with this disease right here and I
showed you the wind pathway last week
and I went through it quickly but you
notice this central protein right here
in this destruction complex that's APC
APC stands for adenomatous polyposis
coli
I'll will rote write that down so
adenomatous
polyposis coli okay and what a PC does
is as represented in that slide above is
it's part of this destruction complex
that destroys beta catenin which is the
downstream step of wind signaling so the
wild type function of a PC is to
basically inhibit beta catenin which
then is mediating the effects of wind
signaling okay so you can think of a PC
as one of the genes that's the break on
wind signaling okay and normally it's
regulated by wynt
right but if you so wint would normally
inhibit a PC but if you just delete a PC
in a cell then it's like the cell is
seeing went all the time so by deleting
a PC you get a constitutive activation
of beta catenin and you get constitutive
active activation of wind signaling so
if the organism starts out being
heterozygous for a PC then there's a
high probability that a second meet
another mutation will take out the wild
type function of a PC or the wild type
allele of it and when you take out that
allele now you all of a sudden start
having these cells that are basically
feeling like your seats
it's like they are always seeing wynt
even though they're not okay and so if
you constitutively active eight when
signaling what that does is it prevents
the cells from leaving the go organ okay
so they're stuck okay so normally you
know in a normal colon cells that are
renewed at the bottom of the crypt they
move up and then they're shed into the
lumen but in an APC a mutant they the
cells are constantly feeling like
they're getting wind signal and so they
stay in the colon and that allows them
to a
accumulate further mutations okay so
step step one in colon cancer is to
dysregulated signaling and that really
disrupts the whole tissue homeostatic
mechanism of the intestine okay then
there would be further steps at least
three usually in colon cancer and that
would involve mutations uncle genic
mutations loss of tumor suppressors and
that would just cause the the cells to
get more and more oncogenic and more and
more transformed and eventually they can
become invasive and we'll talk about
what happens when cells become invasive
invasive next week alright so I wanted
to end today's lecture by talking about
targeted treatments for cancer just to
see how they interface with the
mechanisms that we've discussed and of
course you know some of the primary ways
to treat cancer are through surgery and
also chemotherapy but there are also
more directed ways to target cancer and
because time's up
yes well I have one minute I'll tell you
about the first one and then I'll if I
have more to go I'll start with that and
next week's lecture so the first one I
wanted to tell you about is this disease
chronic myelogenous myelogenous leukemia
which involves activation of the able
gene and it's activated in this case by
a translocation between two different
chromosomes so this is chromosome 22
this is chromosome 9 and in many
patients with chronic myelogenous
leukemia a large part of chromosome 22
is translocated onto chromosome 9 and a
little bit of chromosome 9 is attached
to chromosome 2 and this translocation
generates a gene fusion between the BCR
gene and the able gene okay
and so Abel is a non receptor tyrosine
kinase so it's a tyrosine kinase that is
present in the cytoplasm in the cell and
promotes growth so this is a
proto-oncogene and when Abel becomes
hooked up to BCR then this results in
the constitutive activation of BCR Abel
okay so this is now constitutively
active kinase now when this was realized
then researchers started looking for
small molecules that would inhibit the
kinase activity of Abel and the famous
example is Gleevec and this is a picture
of Gleevec here you can see it's a small
molecule and what Gleevec does is now
this is a crystal structure of the Abel
tyrosine kinase in green and it has two
lobes an n-terminal lobe a C terminal
lobe like a lot of kinase --is and what
Gleevec does is to bind in the interface
between these two lobes and it locks
this kinase in an inactive conformation
such that if cells see this Gleevec then
they're able tyrosine kinase is
inhibited and this is the driver of
chronic myelogenous leukemia
so Gleevec has been very effective in
treating this type of leukemia and it
results in a pretty good prognosis for
patients alright so we'll talk about
more therapies next Wednesday but have a
good holiday weekend
you